hi
this presentation is observability best
practices for reliability for reliably
running apps on vms
i'm rahul harpalani but my friends call
me harp i'm a product manager at google
cloud focused on observability and
specifically telemetry which is the
capturing of metrics and logs to enable
ops management i'm joined here by my
partner ling
ling would you like to introduce
yourself
sure thing hey everyone my name is lin
i'm so glad to be here today and i'm
working very closely with harp on the
cloud ops instrumentation efforts
driving mainly from the technical side
as the to of the team
and you're gonna see me again at the
demo time towards the end of this
presentation harp i'm gonna hand it back
to you now
thanks lang
in this presentation we'll be walking
through observability within virtual
machines
recently the 2021 report on accelerating
the state of devops
found that teams who excel at modern
operational practices are 40 percent
more likely to report greater software
delivery and operational performance and
80 percent more likely to report better
business outcomes when they fully invest
in managing operations at scale so as
you can see setting up blogging and
monitoring and making sure you're
collecting the right telemetry data is
the first important step of day two
operations
this helps you run a reliable
application and triangulate if when and
where something went wrong
as a foreshadow we're going to focus a
lot on the value of our agent there are
many great resources for deeper dives
into the cloud ops suite for
visualization
alerting and other logging and
monitoring capabilities
i recommend you go to the youtube
i recommend you go to youtube and search
stackdoctor to learn more
there is a lot of buzz around containers
and kubernetes but many of us are still
running on vms and plan to do so for the
foreseeable future
especially as more customers are doing a
lift and shift migration from their
on-prem environments we often hear
how can i set up my applications and vms
to run on the cloud while simultaneously
learning all the features google cloud
has to offer running apps reliably on
vms is not does not happen without good
telemetry
data about your applications about your
processes about your systems are
essential to delivering a high quality
experience
i'm going to spend roughly the next 10
minutes
walking through some of the challenges
that i constantly hear about i'll review
the guiding principles we use in vm
observability to address these
challenges
then i'll give an overview of the ops
agent the single client-side solution
for logging and monitoring
we'll then get a demo from ling where
she'll walk through installing the ops
agent using popular open source
configuration tooling
and finally we'll leave some time for
questions
all right let's jump in
as a product manager some questions i
often ask our users are
are you running vms in more than one
environment
are you operating in hybrid or a
multi-cloud environment
what solutions are you using for
monitoring versus logging
do you have to leverage multiple
client-side agents to capture
telemetry and what tools are you using
to provision install configure and
manage your agents
these questions usually lead to one
conclusion
complexity
simply put users have tons of vms that
need to be instrumented with one or more
agents
these agents need to be managed with one
or more tools and even the thought of
migration can be stress inducing
let's quickly visualize this to put this
problem in perspective
often we think of only our own
environments and despite this
downscoping it still can be hectic
when we start to think about all the
permutations i just discussed beyond our
own workloads and think about this issue
at enterprise scale with tens of
thousands of vms the problem of
complexity becomes glaring
for this reason integrations to me for
this reason the integration between
google cloud and cloud ops is a game
changer in reducing complexity
and why we at cloud ops believe having
an integrated solution that meets you
where you are is very important in
helping you manage and reduce your ops
burden
when we think about simplification we
think about the agent
for this reason we embrace several
principles in making our latest agent
the ops agent
industry leading in its user-friendly
focus
fewer agents
this starts right here at google cloud
up until a couple of months ago we had
two agents one for logging and one for
monitoring we've invested heavily in a
single unified agent to reduce the
number of agents and complexity our
users must manage
number two the ability to manage our
agents at scale by investing in
solutions to easily support the most
popular config management tools that
most of our users are already leveraging
simple configuration the ops agent only
has one configuration file making it
simple to manage both logging and
monitoring
finally third-party application support
here at cloud ops we're making the move
from monitoring the platform to also
monitoring popular applications
we don't think that requiring you to
install extra agents or extra software
to capture this data is something that
makes sense or is a good use of your
time so we're building this capability
into the ops agent
one thing that's not on the slide and is
crucial to our strategy is our
investment in open source
we know the overall story to telemetry
is not cutting it for all operations
users and that includes our own users as
well as everyone else's
customers are simply juggling too many
agents
too many protocols and too many ways to
capture to lump to the lemma tree
in this vein we decided to go beyond a
new agent and stake out a path forward
that would make capturing telemetry
easier for all of our users
and we are doing this by committing and
supporting open observability standards
the ops agent is built to support the
future of application and system
telemetry which is being democratized
through open source
we've incorporated two important open
source technologies into the ops agent
first
fluent bit
fluent bit is an open source log
processor and forwarder which allows you
to collect logs with incredibly high
throughput and resource efficiency
the second technology is open telemetry
this is a cncf supported
open source and vendor neutral
technology and is at the forefront of
unifying operations
it has garnered the support of many
vendors in the op space and the cloud
ops agent emphasizes
our belief
that
this technology will lead to
interoperability within the ops
community
we've worked very close within the with
the open telemetry community and through
this effort
much of which is frontier territory we
are helping to guide the greater
telemetry community to a place that is
optimized for you the user
i mentioned these topics earlier but i
wanted to specifically call out how we
are meeting our users where they are
what i what i hear from customers all
the time
is that they are overwhelmed with all of
the tools they have to manage and learn
to use
that's why we made sure that the ops
agent could be managed by the open
source configuration and provisioning
tools that you're already using such as
terraform ansible puppet and chef and of
course our in-house option vm manager
in the demo which ling will run shortly
you will see the installation of the ops
agent handled by ansible
additionally i mentioned the support for
third-party applications
currently we support nginx and jvm but
we have an aggressive rollout schedule
for the rest of this year to include
apache my sequel redis and many more
in 2022
we're gonna increase the support by 50
additional third-party applications
directly
built into the ops agent
finally i want to review our integration
with gcp
while the ops agent is built on open
telemetry and fluent bit for the
efficient collection of telemetry it is
purpose built
to support our own operation suite which
includes cloud monitoring and logging
with the operation suite we want you to
have reliability without sacrificing
agility
as you'll see in the demo data from
cloud logging and cloud monitoring is
made available directly in context in
google compute engine and many other gcp
services have similar integrations
time for the demo ling are you ready
ready for a demo
so in this demo we're going to show you
how to use the google cloud ops agent
and support role to install the ops
agent on the fleet of vms and then
configure the ops agent to monitor nginx
applications
and at the end of the demo we're going
to go to the console ui so that way we
can show you
how to pull the nginx dashboard template
and create a real dashboard
out of it
so other details of this tutorial can be
fine on our public documentation site as
well
just so you can check it out later
now let's get started
um in this demo environment i have
already finished installing some basic
setups so that
those parts are tedious and not fun too
much
so i installed ansible
i installed the
google cloud ops agent role i set up a
service account for the project download
the service account key to my
workstation
and set up an environmental variable for
it
i also finished setting up my local ssh
key
which is what ansible will be using to
talk to the vms
so
let's go to the actual fun stuff
first let's take a look at the ansible
inventory we have
so here we are using a plugin called gcp
compute
to help manage the gc vms
um this plugin uses the service account
to authenticate
and it will list all the vms
in the link she dash sandbot
sandbox project
and it will also show
the public ip of those vms and ansible
will later use these addresses to ssh
into those vms
before we kick off this playbook
let's first ensure that ansible can
actually successfully talk to those vms
we are targeting at
so we can use ansible to quickly pin
them to make sure they are
the connection is aligned
cool
great the connections looks okay
so
now let's dive a little bit into the
actual ansible playbook
um oh actually let me double check that
the installation of the answer raw is
successful yeah i already installed this
before so
it's already installed as it shows
um the examples playbook we are using
today looks like this
looks pretty simple right we are
basically asking ansibo to install the
latest version of ops agent
with a custom configuration file on all
the host that we have in the inventory
now you might wonder what is in that ops
agent config yamo well that's a good
question
basically our ops agent by default
collects some system metrics and logs
however we can customize it
to collect more locks and metrics from
third-party applications
and in this example we are collecting
metrics and logs from nginx
on the metric side
i have already pre-installed nginx on
those vms
and
the metrics exposed via their stop
status module so the key in this
configuration part is
to make sure that the ops agent knows
basically which url it should be using
to talk to the stop status module of the
nginx application to collect the metrics
and then on the login side we collect
both nginx access locks and nginx error
locks
okay let's quit this
and now it's the exciting part
let's actually execute the playbook
so
that
the start of the playbook execution is
gonna take
a few minutes
well actually i have executed this
playbook already
so this should return just okay and
while it's running
we can go to the console ui and take a
look at the actual dashboard
so you can reach this page via the
monitoring
dashboards
and the sample library
has a engine next template already
so if you click on this
you can go to this
on genex overview and preview what the
dashboard looks like
um here we're gonna skip that and just
import this sample dashboard so it will
automatically create a dashboard for you
it has a few metrics that
tracking already
and you can show that
it's tracking the few vms we created
before
and it shows the
total request coming to the nginx server
it shows the current connections it also
shows the history history of the
connections
and of course you can also added this
added this dashboard or add more chart
to this dashboard
because nginx
does ingest more than just these three
metrics
on the other side we mentioned before
that ops agent also collects some system
metrics right
so
the most imp
most interesting one might be the
processes metrics
um
if we go to the dashboard list
there is gcp dashboard
and one of them says vm instances
if we go to this page
it shows you a
few tabs of different
property of the vms like you can see cpu
metrics
memory metrics
and
most excitingly
you can see processes metrics
it will tell you
the top processes by memory the top
processes by cpu so
that way you can easily tell
what is using all the resources on the
vm and what could potentially go wrong
um
that's the dashboard part now let's go
back to see if that execution of
playable okay it looks great
the execution of the playbook was
successful
and
that's actually the end of this demo
thank you so much
thank you so much ling for that awesome
demo
as a reminder to those of you tuning in
please use the question and answer forum
which is embedded in this video page
i want to take a minute to show you
other interesting presentations in the
operation space that are happening at
next this week
we're launching a preview of fully
managed prometheus service called manage
service for prometheus if you're running
kubernetes chances are that you're very
familiar with prometheus and how
and how difficult it can be to manage
this new service takes away the pain of
prometheus at scale
we are also launching a preview of a
service that combines logs data with the
power and performance of bigquery
you can learn more about log analytics
what it is and the use cases in that
presentation
finally the integrated cloud ops story
where we talk about how ops tools can be
used to make your development team and
the apps they run more effective
i'd like to thank ling for the demo
and thank our viewers for tuning in